recently i had the pleasure of chatting
with a
very funny man who is very loved in the
comedy world
he's worn so many hats that his hat rack
must be completely
full he's in everything from a show
creator to a talk show host to a killer
podcast interviewer
and his hbo special pete holmes dirty
clean is available now
here is our never seen before
conversation with the hilarious and
thoughtful and i do mean thoughtful
this conversation really kind of changed
my life a little bit
take a look it's a dicey time it can be
hard for
to assume that people are going to
understand your your perspective your
point of view and
and the subtlety of a joke at times and
sometimes people will
collapse on a comedian and give them a
hard time for that
but i i mean i look like a youth pastor
and i sort of do the comedy that a youth
pastor who swears but still
it's clean it's pretty positive stuff i
do like to talk about adult things from
time to time
but when it comes to like oh man i'm
being censored i can't be as edgy as i
want to be
i sort of lucked out me my dear friend
john mullaney mike brabiglia we were
sort of the weirdos coming up
and now it's it's very nice to be uh
sort of safe
from that crossfire you uh even wrote a
book
called comedy sex god and
you're able to bring religion into
comedy which is a
very unique balancing act how do you do
that
it's tricky to tease religion i made
uh grew up religious so i have a lot of
love for religious people and a lot of
respect for religious people obviously
but when it came time to write the book
i really wanted to
reduce spirituality to its core
something that we could all agree on
on my podcast almost everybody so many
actors and
and famous people might say that they
don't believe in anything
but if you get talking to them you
realize that
usually they have some sort of belief
underneath it they're just afraid of
being
religious they're afraid of belonging to
a group and that's what i wanted to talk
about in the book was
we're all we all woke up in a mystery
we woke up in a conundrum that none of
us asked for
it's a surprise and we're floating on a
rock in space
that's hurling through infinity and
we're self-aware
and what do you make of that not not
just like what group do you belong to
what building do you worship in
but just like how do you tell yourself a
story how do you make
sense of the understandable and that
that to me is what spirituality is
something you can experience you can't
know it but you can become it
if that makes sense ah wow
i really and truly because one of the
things that's
funny i am i want to be a spiritual
person as well
and you know there are so many
meaningful conversations which is again
hard to find where you put the comedy
especially if you go to
heavy deep dark places and that's
immediately when i need the comedy the
most it's like okay good lighten me up
here
but what you just said about waking up
to the mystery
someone said to me walk in this room i'm
going to show you around now i'm going
to turn the lights off
and i want you to pretend that you don't
know what this room looks like
you can't and what you just said about
waking up in this mystery
is gonna live with me forever that is so
profound
i think comedy is essential you have to
have a sense of humor about what's going
on here
and that's why i always turn back to
spiritual traditions i
i grew up with jesus and i still lean on
him quite a bit
but i found a lot of value in other
traditions as well
because we sort of need all the help we
can get you have your dark room
but try explaining wi-fi to my dog brody
like
it's not gonna work but it feels really
good when you're quiet enough and
and you can sort of feel it intuitive
merge with it
flow with it even if you can't get your
brain to fully grasp it
literally i'm hanging on every single
word i just it's so amazing i just think
that people
when they get to listen to you are
getting
so much to think about do you
and your lovely wife val you have a
two-year-old daughter leela
do you think that she has her dad's
sense of humor and
my goodness life perspective that's my
whole goal and that's part of the reason
why we named her leela leela is a
it's actually from the hindu tradition
it's a word that means the dance
of life or the play of the universe
and she is exactly that she's always
present
she's always in awe this is her twerking
i was gonna say pete we have a video of
her twerking which is just
isn't being a parent the craziest thing
we'll ever do
in this hurling rock type of experience
well drew you're a mother and in my case
i'm the dad but my
val was sleeping next to me when leela
became
a thing became a separate entity and
that is a miracle
and that's what i see when i when i hang
out with leela somebody that understands
doesn't take anything for granted
sprinklers are a miracle
twerking is a miracle getting up at 5am
is a miracle like she
she gets up not because she's crying but
because she has a passion for life
because she doesn't have a story one of
my favorite teachers byron katie says if
you want a problem have a future
and i think that's where so many of our
problems come from it's like
you drew you're doing this new show if
you're feeling stressed it's probably
because you're thinking about something
you will be doing uh something will that
go well or how's this going to turn out
or
will i be tired or will i have the right
food beforehand
but leela has none of that the needle is
right on the record
so she's just playing completely in the
present so that's why she's so joyful
and that's what i want us to be that's
the key to life just do what you're
doing when you're doing it and do it
fully
even if you are getting up at 3 30 in
the morning to rock your baby
drop the story what does 3 30 in the
morning mean
i'm thinking of a future where i'm going
to be tired because my baby woke up but
that's not happening yet
right now i'm just holding the love of
my life in the dark
what is the problem
i'm so glad that leela has you i mean it
just
thank god can you imagine like a parent
talking to you like this
oh my god pete jesus if i may say that
that really speaks to your heart that
you can hear that and that you know
that you recognize that as love that
means you have that love in you that's
beautiful
yeah what an incredible person